It was one of the longest relationships of my
life, and certainly one of the happiest.
The repairman confirmed my suspicion.
The manifold valve and the right front
burner had rusted through.
I guess everyone remembers where they were
when Kitchen King discontinued their deluxe
six burner flattop.
I'm sorry, I cannot publish this.
Too long?
Does it come with a forklift?
Thank you, Terry.
No, it's not just about the length, Adrian.
We hired you to write about your career as a
police detective.
You solved 140 homicides.
That's the story we paid for.
Not this. Oh.
Here in chapter four, you have two
paragraphs about the suspect and seven,
eight, nine pages about his vacuum cleaner.
We have the same vacuum cleaner, the exact
same model. What are the odds of that?
1 in.
6?
Terence.
Maybe I need an editor.
You've had five editors and two ghost
writers. They all quit.
The last one changed his name and moved to
Guam. I've talked to the lawyers.
You're illegally in breach.
We need our advance back.
Advance, you mean? You mean the money?
It's not my decision.
I'm sorry. Adrian.
No no no no no, you can't do that.
Here's the thing. Molly's getting married in
six weeks. Molly?
Trudy's daughter.
I didn't even know about her until 12 years
ago. It's all in the book.
I mean, it will be in volume two.
Is there something wrong with the chair?
It's not plum with cherries.
It should be plum.
Maybe you could lower yours.
Why? To make it plum.
You'll thank me later.
Oh, please don't.
You got to pull up on the lever.
Good.
Maybe I'll just stand.
Maybe we should all stand.
Here's the thing, Molly is all I have.
She's all I have left.
She practically saved my life.
When Covid hit, I was in pretty bad shape.
Molly moved in with me.
She never left my side for a year and a
half. She's only ever asked me for one thing
. To pay for her wedding.
I'll do whatever you want. I'll rewrite the
book.
I'm sorry, Adrian.
It's just too late. It's been ten years.
The name Adrian Monk used to mean something.
It's a different world now.
Everyone's moved on.
I have an idea.
May I make a suggestion?
You both leave the room and someone
different comes in and says different things
to me.
That's not going to happen.
How about this? You leave the room and nobody
comes back in.
Ever.
I think we're done here.
Our lawyers will be in touch.
Adrian. What are you doing?
Nothing. Let's back away.
Take a step away from the window.
Here we go. Adrian.
You have to stop thinking about that.
But now they're taking the money back.
Yes. I know I was there.
It was for her wedding.
I promised Molly.
I'm so.
I'm just so.
Going down?
The wedding is off.
Excuse me
? Hey.
Sorry. Excuse me.
I'm sorry. Excuse me.
Okay. I checked the board and they just
landed.
Where did you get this? I've ruined
everything.
Adrian, for the hundredth time, it's fine.
You did us a favor. I always wanted a small
wedding.
Oh, Molly.You don't have to say that.
It's true. The backyard is going to be
perfect. And Griffin is, frankly relieved
because now he doesn't have to invite his
cousins from hell.
Okay.
Better safe. Thank you very much.
Wow.
Look at that. They were handing these out.
Everybody's you.
They're going to hate it.
Oh, I think I see her.
Hey! Molly! So good to see you.
Okay, let's see it. Okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh a tattoo.
Yeah. Okay, I love it.
Griffin has one too.
At least you won't lose it, right?
Oh. There he is.
Hello, boss.
I've missed you.
Natalie.
You can't still be mad at me.
What was I supposed to do?
Steven transferred.
I had to leave.
We've talked about this.
People commute from Atlanta.
I thought you'd be happy for me.
Please be happy for me.
I have a wonderful life.
Really? Julie lives ten minutes away.
I sold 27 houses last year.
I'm my
Own boss. Adrian.
Adrian. This woman was your assistant for 12
years. Which is a record that will never,
ever be broken.
So, say I'm so glad you're here.
I'm so glad you're here.
Say I've missed you.
I have missed you.
Oh, thank you, Mr.
Monk. I missed you, too.
Oh. Oh.
Where's Leland? Oh, he just texted.
He couldn't get off work.
I thought he retired.
He did for about 20 minutes, and then he took
another gig. But nobody knows what he's
doing. It's top secret.
Oh. Oh. Randy.
Hey, stranger. Hey.
Wow. You look great.
So good to see you. Oh, hey, are you ready
for this? I guess face your own sensor,
love. You have to stay and help with the
baby.
I heard Benji is a dad.
Congrats, grandpa.
Step-grandpa!
Okay, okay, let's see some pictures.
Come on, let's see it.
Oh, that's not all.
Guess who is just re-elected sheriff of
Summit, New Jersey for the third time.
It's no big deal.
Oh.
Hey, Monk, how you doing?
Are you here to apologize?
No, I'm here for the wedding.
Oh, he thinks we abandoned him.
It was more of a betrayal, actually.
But you told me to take the job you
recommended me.
Maybe I wasn't thinking straight.
Maybe I was distracted by the knife in my
back.
Okay. I need your help.
Will you go get my bag? It's right over
here. It's black.
How's he doing?
It's hard to say.
You know, after he solved Trudy's murder, he
was doing better. I mean, you guys were
there. He was.
He was just functioning.
He was functioning more or less.
But then the pandemic hit, and it was just
boom. Back to square one.
I mean, he didn't leave the house for two
years. And then he started taking those
in-home rapid tests.
And it was like an addiction.
He was testing himself every 20 minutes.
I'm pretty sure that cocaine would have been
a cheaper habit.
Then about three weeks ago, they cancelled
his book deal. No.
Yeah. And now I'm more worried than ever.
What do you mean? Well, it's just like he's
giving up. I mean, he hardly talks anymore.
He just sits around all day and stares out
the window. What are you doing?
You'll thank me later.